just me I don't have guests I haven't
only maybe I just sit Chris D'Elia and
that's all I said no I know but maybe
I'll have guests and if I do start
having yes thank you
no you know what dude it is thank you so
much I'm telling you cuz you're my
[ __ ] friend dude all right I mean you
said it like I'm doing you throwing your
line or what stop what I meant
but it probably would be good yeah thank
you I meant alright so I want to look
everybody just [ __ ] go and subscribe
my [ __ ] - all right all right what is it
under that's right you go to iTunes yeah
iTunes right it's called congratulations
yeah and it's just you Chris D'Elia
when does it when dude when do you every
Monday night it comes out it comes so
you already recorded Sunday I already
recorded Monday and it comes out that
same yeah you already did today yes I
did okay I don't what does this go up
for night tomorrow night yeah so you say
today and now everyone thinks it's
[ __ ] Tuesday it was yesterday
everybody yesterday yeah yeah okay but
anyway so if you're listening that if
it's Tuesday 9:00 Wednesday morning and
you're listening into it and no one died
and everything's fine yeah some people
died no I don't mean that dude I just
mean like I know that that's really sad
it's so [ __ ] sad yep if you guys
don't know Bill Paxton is you gotta go
[ __ ] yourself because you know number
one he was in aliens too and he was so
funny in that do you remember that yeah
yeah you know what he was so funny and
what is true lies and then a simple plan
there was a move a little movie that I
never saw that you should see it yeah I
will yeah you should no plans so good
yeah so good Raimi directed it yeah yeah
but he was young
yeah yeah you know I I read something
where it was just supposed to be like a
routine like heart surgery to like fix
his like valves and he got out of
surgery I think healthy and then he had
a stroke like or there he threw a clot
or something like that
my god it can go that fast yeah cos 60
is so young I mean yeah yeah I just saw
him he looked great well would you see
him at at the grocery store I can't
remember which one but I was oh you saw
him walking around just being all
[ __ ] bill paxton yeah I think he was
healthy other other than in like a small
little like glitch in his heart that was
supposed to be a routine shut your
[ __ ] that's so funny ask you this
when you work with Ray Liotta was he
nice yeah yeah he seems like a guy that
could probably he could probably be both
yeah yeah it wasn't like I was like oh
you know sometimes you you meet somebody
and you're like oh that's just a nice
guy I think really other was just nice
to me Jeremy which is by the way those
are I like those people better I don't
just want some guy always [ __ ] nice
so Tom Hanks right he's notorious a nice
dad you see I've never met him yeah yeah
but if he is so let me go make a
happiness bully cuz I can't stand those
either when they're constantly nice and
in-your-face about their niceness then
it just it yeah it's like they're
telling you to go [ __ ] yourselves yeah
like who's always nice deep Simone yeah
but that doesn't count
yeah you can tell that he's not
something inside yeah you know what I'm
saying no I didn't send a negative way
Steve Simone's funny and he's always
nice but always that's not what I mean I
mean I don't know I can't think of
somebody but yeah but um let's think of
a mean comedian who's a guy that's
always mean do you have anyone that you
don't get along with you don't want to
say it you don't well but I also don't I
don't think you do yeah well there was
that thing between you and Dane that
that was a long time but that's done
yeah yeah yeah is that done yeah for
sure 100%
okay talk about that or no is there's
nothing that you did wrong no but I
don't I mean what happens I don't know
what happened
Gordo thank you that's see that's why
let me say something right now man - you
Gilbert all right yeah Bobby that's why
you're here
what you just did right there you threw
me a little [ __ ] volley and it goes a
long way friend yeah okay and I know I
say that you have a flat face Yeah right
and that you're you know it's really
nice though thank you so much you don't
wear makeup on no that's amazing yeah
right you wear makeup for no pores uh
very little very little to your car
said that so many people kept coming up
to me a career well you say he looks
like her that is her anyway um so thank
you so much no people blue that way out
of proportion no they did yeah okay so
he didn't go out of his way to bump you
and stuff at clubs I don't know Oh
physical no people would always come up
to me and maple wanted to make that a
big deal right and juicy yeah to me Dan
to me was you know he's I've never had a
problem with them yeah I I like them but
alright if you don't want to talk about
it but my belief though is is that that
is that is true well and you know no
offense to Dana he's never done anything
to me and I shouldn't even said this
because I want to start a war with
anybody
I make life so [ __ ] difficult for
myself he does by talking yeah but yeah
but you're not gonna start a war he's a
good guy he likes you you like him life
but here's what here's where you start
oh here's where you make life difficult
for yourself tell me you think you make
life difficult for yourself and then
it's been it's bad that's the thing you
think you go on stage you do what you do
and you come off and you sometimes you
say off or can I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
the crowd this and that and you didn't
but you're doing that makes it worse
does that annoy you I think maybe this
isn't about me and it's about you and I
should be saying that when I do that
does that annoy you a very little bit
yeah it knows a lot of people it's more
detrimental to you than anybody else
around you it's less annoying and more
just like you don't have to do that
buddy yeah you know Whitney Cummings
said that to me one night she goes I'm
tired of you [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah it was the first time where I
literally looked at myself in the
America is that annoying and it is
annoying you shouldn't worry about
whether or not it's annoying to other
people as much as it's probably not good
for your psyche overall yeah yeah you do
I'm not texting was it was something
more important no I was just looking
[Laughter]
[Music]